tells ago breasts and welcome to super
amazing wagon adventure [ __ ] yeah
and only that I don't know much about
the game I just know it has super
amazing in it
that's synapse to sell a game for me
start a venture [ __ ] yet okay
between 1830 and 1870 nearly half a
million straight story yep
alright generalize meme Oregon Trail so
we got Robert Robert has swag Laura is
not okay let's go they travel are they
[ __ ] with me the standard completely
average the random the fantasy unlocked
by magic whoa I want these
alright well day one they set up this
should be good can tell her oh my god
those graphics squirrels ice guns oh
[ __ ] they make why are we killing them I
don't want to kill them kill them all
[ __ ] yeah more a pulse abet get the [ __ ]
away from me
you stupid [ __ ] you think you can
[ __ ] with me I got oh they became ashes
what is this lasers of course a machine
gun armed bandit oh [ __ ] a boss battle
[ __ ] love the music it's pretty bad
at the Battle passed through the
largeness okay
Oh skunks the best story ever written
day 13 left the wagon and can I get a
chance to [ __ ] read please
hand-to-hand combat shoot all the
blueberry bushes isn't me order this is
something that made me happy on hits
okay
a cave it was very darkest no [ __ ]
Sherlock
upon lightning a torch he found it was
oh [ __ ] not bad anything but the bath
George ran from the cave back to the
wagon
day 19 their feelings Oh feeling skip
see hearts is nice sweet they reach her
okay what now jump jump
they made the decision up there were a
lot of boulders [ __ ] me some what
okay finally they reach the other side
of okay fine they entered the great oh
yeah this music they came across a large
chair to Buffalo
sorry buffaloes this I don't really like
it I thought but genius that that that
writing is so good can't believe this
game has not been influenced so many
people in their life
I mean buffalo Buffalo buffalo lasers
the number of Buffalo was absurd but I
wanted the lasers whoa what the [ __ ]
what I'm shooting rocks why the Potters
journey ended there
go jump yes somehow they made it across
however they landed in a business oh no
not the BJS baby a safe son of a [ __ ]
the giant beats thank Tina in the knee
that's a deadly blow right there [ __ ]
love the music they entered into the
croquette here we go again
see if I do better this time around the
wagon picked up by the chin okay cool
are we flying right now along with da
God average [ __ ] buffaloes everywhere
god I hate buffaloes lasers Michela left
the wagon to walk to the nearest
Michelle what are you doing
coyotes oh no not the Coyotes good thing
Michelle has a laser
[ __ ] off coyote everyone knows coyotes
greatest weakness is lasers and arrows
finally Michelle reached ok hello ok
travel bike
they great I said this is like the new
Playstation 4 graphics holy [ __ ] and
I've thought about it it's pretty good
Michelle had the brilliant idea to swim
underwater through the river swim they
took a deep breath and jumped in they
face deadly what piranhas of course what
else would it be
god dammit they got George
narwhals oh [ __ ] Michelle landed on a
small island to catch her breath good
I shall notice some supply sitting on
the beach she'll let the wagon to
investigate cool Michelle then I
realized why the supplies were left
there the beach was infested with giant
called ah crabs nothing but the crabs
Michelle run back to the wagon Michelle
quickly left the island and swam to the
shore of the river Michelle entered a
mountain path the music is so [ __ ]
dope 84 food supplies for lip something
a snowstorm again
and wool house [ __ ]
[ __ ] what that [ __ ] is going I'm doing
it the wagon passes through a flock of
oh not too close oh [ __ ] me ah what do
you doing here crows what are you doing
here crows what are you doing here crows
what do you don't win here crows
luckily the wagon landed on a ribbon the
wagon now we're back was heavier down
the river by the current I know what I
just said what I like it Julie I fell
out the wagon
[ __ ] oh I can shoot them
by stones for some reason there were a
bunch of Paulo Gators for some [ __ ]
reason no I'm Nessen [ __ ] so I was
super amazing [ __ ] [ __ ] I don't even
know that was pretty fun I'm surprised
and like legitimately a cool game yeah
maybe like you know watching hit
subscribe comment with me I'll see in
the next 1000 breath
you